es una carrera para liberar el grano
bloqueado de ucrania antes de una crisis
alimentaria mundial turquía quiere
desempeñar el papel de mediador para
ayudar a liberarlo cerca de 30 millones
de toneladas de grano que están
atascados en los puertos ucranianos
podemos establecer un mecanismo una
colaboración entre ucrania rusia y
turquía para aplicar este plan xeral
turquía cree que este plan es factible
el ministro de asuntos exteriores turco
y su homólogo ruso se reunieron el
miércoles en ankara mientras naciones
unidas- piden corredores seguros que
permitan enviar el grano de kiev desde
los puertos clave que están bajo su
control incluido el de odessa turquía
controla quien entra y sale del mar
negro lo que le confiere un poder
marítimo único el gobierno turco ha
criticado la invasión rusa y se ha
ofrecido a ayudar a ucrania a examinar
su costa pero quien le preocupa que
pueda dejar de esa y otros puertos clave
abiertos a un ataque ruso intenciones
que fueron negadas por moscú
estamos dispuestos a garantizar la
seguridad de los barcos que salgan de
los puertos ucranianos y lo haremos en
cooperación con nuestros colegas turcos
de otros otros historias que
rusia quiere que se levanten las
sanciones occidentales como condición
para poner fin al bloqueo lo que turquía
dijo que era una demanda legítima el
país necesitaría el apoyo de moscú si
llevan a cabo una operación contra las
fuerzas del partido de los trabajadores
del kurdistán en el norte de siria un
tema que los dos líderes también
discutieron el miércoles con mariupol
ahora bajo control ruso la gran mayoría
del grano ucraniano está atascado en
odessa la onu teme que el bloqueo ruso
pueda llevar a millones de personas a la
hambruna debido al aumento de los costos
especialmente en áfrica donde los
precios ya han subido más de un 20 por
ciento